Classroom 410: Very off.
Classroom 410: Yeah, I get you.
Classroom 410: Yeah.
Classroom 410: yeah, hold on a second.
Classroom 410: It's maybe just click.
Classroom 410: Yeah, come on.
Classroom 410: I mean, it's just like with 30 questions.
Classroom 410: Can you sign into it?
Classroom 410: It was like
Classroom 410: the Zoom Meeting took us.
Classroom 410: please do.
Classroom 410: Because yeah.
Classroom 410: Then this one.
Classroom 410: all right, who went the furthest for fall break. I'm very jealous because Professor Lewis and I were here working
Classroom 410: anybody go somewhere interesting.
Classroom 410: There's somebody lying to me right now.
Classroom 410: Nothing. You got nothing. Anybody go somewhere uninteresting. Yeah.
Classroom 410: Charleston, how was the weather? It was really beautiful.
Classroom 410: Charleston has the best food, I'm told, on the East Coast.
Classroom 410: Anything else exciting.
Classroom 410: You all know we're halfway done right.
Classroom 410: Does it seem like we're halfway done?
Classroom 410: It sneaks up on me. This is my
Classroom 410: I think this is officially my 18th year teaching. It's like, Oh, my God! I can't believe we're already done, and I say it every year. Oh, my gosh!
Classroom 410: It's already Thanksgiving as well.
Classroom 410: Alright. Last plug before we get going.
Classroom 410: Who here is planning on attending the fall Forum on Friday.
Classroom 410: y'all are go-getters, huh? Have you know about the Fall Forum on Friday.
Classroom 410: If Jonathan Gray from Blackstone it is gonna be
Classroom 410: yeah. He's very difficult to get. He's going to say some really interesting things. So if you could figure out a way to get to old Kabul, and it's not even 1st thing in the morning. I think it starts at 1030. We made it student friendly as well, but it's a great chance to to hear from really one of the thought leaders of finance in the world.
Classroom 410: One of the things he does, too, is he does these run and running kind of Tiktok videos, which are kind of neat. So he talks about
Classroom 410: kind of all things macroeconomics, etc. So quick plug for the fall. Forum.
Classroom 410: If you're not thinking about it, that's 1030 on Friday, let's talk a little bit about our cybersecurity class. So like I said, we're now in week, 8 out of a 15 week class. We are halfway through as well. We got some guests coming in, and all sorts of different ways.
Classroom 410: So I want to introduce you to our system for sourcing kind of guest questions, and also the way that I prefer to do cases today. And this is why we're going to have a couple of systems coming in. We're going to have a red team are coming in, and then a good friend, Carrie Pearlson, is going to come in and talk about all the things that Mit is talking about with cyber security
Classroom 410: as well. I'm actually going up there presenting at the mit event next week, and hope to bring back kind of some cool stuff that they're thinking about doing
Classroom 410: back with us, so we can talk about that as we're going through. So, as I told Professor Lewis.
Classroom 410: there's some days. That you have your favorite lecture topic.
Classroom 410: This is not my favorite lecture topic Day. I'll just be clear about that when we're talking about policies, procedures. It is not the sexiest thing there is to talk about cybersecurity. But frankly, it's probably the one of the most important things, so it's not anything I could skip, because this is how you articulate your strategy in an organization.
Classroom 410: So it's critical. We understand these things. My goal is to get through it. And here's the ask. I need your help with questions, topics, concerns. So I don't bore myself to tears talking about policy. So anything that you have going along. So we're going to try something a little bit different.
Classroom 410: And I'm going to be doing some warm calling on folks about the reading and these topics, and I call warm calling is because I'm going to give you a chance, as we're going through this at about halfway through, also doing some warm calling.
Classroom 410: Write down your question right now, so you'll have it so you don't have to think about it, or in the 1st little bit of the class.
Classroom 410: so I might say, hey, Matt, what's your question about what we've talked about already, or some things in the reading, and then you'll talk about. That's a fair, warm call right rather than tell me about what an Slsa does and how many days it should be. Think that's an unfair cold call, I would say right? So just jot something down. Be prepared to answer that question. So we can talk about those. Does that make sense
Classroom 410: any question about what's coming down the pipe for you all.
Classroom 410: And I'll talk about these guest speaker discussion questions in a second.
Classroom 410: but we have another reading quiz, and then believe it or not.
Classroom 410: we are already going to be talking about the next group. Exam, so you know what the last group exam. Look like. It's going to be the same type of format, just different questions.
Classroom 410: And, in fact, in the in the group exams that we've designed this next round, you're going to be doing things like critiquing Chat Gpt's answer for certain topics or critiquing chat. Gpt's critique of how to approach different problems, and the only way you know how to do that is using all the information you have and say, Oh, this is right, this is wrong. This is what I've changed those types of things.
Classroom 410: So that will be your group exam, which is due on the 10.th So circle that date. Start planning for that. Then we're going to move into MoD 3, which is all about response. So we know the technology. We know the attackers.
Classroom 410: It's time to build response strategies on how we respond as a team. So some cool stuff coming down the pipeline
Classroom 410: today is a day we're just gonna get through together. If anybody needs a hug afterwards, just let me know
Classroom 410: I might need a hug afterwards. Actually.
Classroom 410: So let's talk about the guest speaker questions.
Classroom 410: The 1st thing is.
Classroom 410: is as the guest speakers come in. We're going to ask that you submit a question based. So you would go to the link, look up who they are. Look at the topic and say, would be interesting to ask this particular person.
Classroom 410: You'll pop it in the discussion question on canvas. And then, after you pop in a discussion question on canvas, you're going to see everybody else's discussion question unless you're the very first, st then you're not going to see everybody else's right. But you're not going to see anybody else's answers. Then what I would do is
Classroom 410: if you're doing it really, really early, like, now come back and just thumbs up the questions that you think are good questions. Does that make sense? So I can kind of crowdsource some interesting conversations, drop them into our conversation about what you all are interested in hearing from these particular speakers. So we have our 2 1st cisos. There's lots of different things that you could talk about. So this is due October 20th at midnight.
Classroom 410: Professor Lewis will be checking it at midnight. Exactly, and start going through these questions.
Classroom 410: And then we'll kind of form these up and will help us drive the discussion. So we'll have several of these discussion questions. They're in canvas. We'll announce them. But this will help. Really, I think, Liven up the conversations when we have guest speakers rather than this thing off the top of my head, you can give it some thought based on the reading you have, or anything that comes to mind. Does that make sense?
Classroom 410: Okay, I know somebody's already done their discussion question
Classroom 410: as well. So, and that's fine. If you if you wanted to delete it and put a new one based on the information you just heard. It was fine. I thought it was a fine question. So that's what we're gonna do for our guest speakers.
Classroom 410: Any questions about that?
Classroom 410: 1st of all, do you see that discussion forum on canvas? Okay?
Classroom 410: As well, this is
Classroom 410: This is why you shouldn't
Classroom 410: be doing canvas changes
Classroom 410: well, sitting beside your wife while she's watching below deck at the same time, and she's more concentrate on things. I set the wrong due date for Lab 4. I don't know if you all noticed with a lab 4 quiz, did you notice that I'm just going to keep it there, even though I meant it to be due
Classroom 410: yesterday. But just keep it there for next week, so I'm not punishing anybody that designed their life around that that was an accident on my part, and so I'll be talking about Lab 4 after everybody's got a chance go through and submit. That quiz, because this is an interesting one, forming a website attack. And Lab 5 is actually one of my favorites as well, as we go through
Classroom 410: these things. Does that make sense any questions
Classroom 410: good? I think we're all on board, you know. I like my reviews.
Classroom 410: So let's start talking about some review topics. I have
Classroom 410: 3 here that I'm interested in talking about. Then I'm going to jump into a case study like I like to do. And it's a case study that has strong implications about policy and how policy actually fall down and created a major breach. But before we do that. Let's do, case. Let's do a softball and give me a quick answer to
Classroom 410: what is the cybersecurity framework?
Classroom 410: Somebody just give me the easiest answer. Elijah's got an easy one. Yeah, there's like, 5 parts is identify, protect, detect, respond, and recover. Yeah. Well, what do I do with that?
Classroom 410: And to use this to like.
Classroom 410: or so I identify
Classroom 410: like different risk. And then you go into like knowing how to protect from identifications.
Classroom 410: and then you detected it from my
Classroom 410: events and moderating, and then you respond with like
Classroom 410: planning or response plans, and then we recover it from an invitation
Classroom 410: improvements, and then, like
Classroom 410: communications. Jeff. Thanks for being the 1st to shout today anything to add about the cybersecurity framework
Classroom 410: who delivers the cybersecurity framework? What did Professor Lewis used to call this before he was corrected by the author.
Classroom 410: the NIST framework as well. So
Classroom 410: this framework and as Elijah led to is the playbook for businesses, this is everything they have to do at a bare minimum to protect themselves from cyber security.
Classroom 410: Right? So what is
Classroom 410: the 1st thing
Classroom 410: you know broadly that you should do? And I asked you this question before, right like, what would you do first? st
Classroom 410: And we went through a bunch of content so hopefully, these answers have changed a little bit. Now, what would you do?
Classroom 410: What's the 1st step when you if you show up to an organization, or you want to get a sense according to the cyber security framework
Classroom 410: and our discussions in class. It's the 1st step. Yeah, we'll figure out what their current like security posture looks like, what tools they're using, like what weaknesses they have and who has access to what? Yeah? So I'll call that. We just take an inventory. Take an inventory of all our assets. We take an inventory of all our policies. That is always the 1st step, because you got to know what you're protecting and how it's protecting before you can engage a red team or do anything other than that. So inventory is key for that as well, good.
Classroom 410: good. And then it goes on about how to respond and how to communicate. We're going to build using Carrie Pearlson's framework. We're going to build out a communication, a crisis communication response plan to cybersecurity tax, which she kind of puts a spin on, which is really really neat. And we'll talk to her a little bit about about how we do these things, and how we do them as businesses.
Classroom 410: So tell me what your advice would be
Classroom 410: for people, for your parents, grandparents, brother sister, that connects to open Wi-fi at airports, hotels, or others. So what's your advice? Don't connect to it. Don't connect to it at all.
Classroom 410: That's 1 approach a very safe approach as well.
Classroom 410: If you are going to connect to it. Connecting?
Classroom 410: Why
Classroom 410: of?
Classroom 410: Because a VPN can protect you from
Classroom 410: twice.
Classroom 410: Yeah, what kind of attack do we call that man in the middle? Yeah. Yeah. Man in the middle attack? Exactly. Right? So, yeah. Be very cautious about open Wi-fi.
Classroom 410: Always use encryption on open Wi-fi, and just assume, if you're not using encryption, they can see all your traffic.
Classroom 410: and if you do that like, I don't care if this person sees me browsing around Espn. Who cares about that?
Classroom 410: That's fine.
Classroom 410: but also the VPN. If you do anything sensitive, or if you don't want them scanning your computer for
Classroom 410: it, affecting malware as well. Good. Any other thoughts. I saw a lot of hands shoot up on that one. Just want to see if anybody had any other advice for open Wi-fi.
Classroom 410: Yeah, it could even be fake password protected Wi-fi. What's preventing me as a man in the middle attack, or let's not use me, because I would never do this. But Marley, for sure, would do this, and let's use her, and she fires up a Wi-fi connection. And this is what's been done. Just puts a web page up there, a fake username and password on it. So any anything you enter will get you access. So you think that it's secure? Yeah.
Classroom 410: and boom! Away you go at a cafe, and they have, like a setup like Wi-fi with the password that you get like. That's fine. It's no, not no, because what Marley could do is set up something that looks really a hotspot that looks really really similar to that and part of her hotspot. It has that same web page that she just grabbed the HTML to use, and any password that anybody enters in will get her, and then you're going to her hotspot instead of the actual hotspot.
Classroom 410: You see what I mean like Vpns is really the way to go for all of this stuff.
Classroom 410: And like I said, the benefit is, you get to watch Netflix anywhere in the world.
Classroom 410: So what you're getting better at. By the way.
Classroom 410: oh.
Classroom 410: what was my last question? Oh.
Classroom 410: somebody! Tell me what malware is
Classroom 410: when people say malware, what do they mean
Classroom 410: when people who know what malware is. What do they mean? That's probably the better word.
Classroom 410: It's malware. Yeah.
Classroom 410: And to like, take information from you.
Classroom 410: they'll give you some examples.
Classroom 410: Yeah, like, that's a Trojan horse. What are some other examples? Worm so like Stuxnet, that was looking for a particular thing. Viruses are the most common. Jonathan
Classroom 410: ransomware which could be like. And then there's gray between these things, Neil
Classroom 410: Rootkit, which are nasty. What do you do when you get a root, Kit? You put your laptop in the dishwasher right? Because you'll never get that thing off.
Classroom 410: As well. Yeah, Adware, we talked a little bit about adware and spyware and things like that. That is
Classroom 410: less obtrusive. The business model, those are. Actually, they're gamifying
Classroom 410: they're utilizing the ad network system. So they get paid. So they surface all these ads for you, and they get paid because they service all these ads for you. But like I didn't want all these ads popping up all over the place. They're getting better and better at those. That's why we see them less and less is because
Classroom 410: that used to be a big thing. Remember, when you got anybody here get infected. And all of a sudden it's like all of a sudden I have this toolbar, and it goes to a weird homepage and things like that that they're monetizing it that way. The ad networks are now more sophisticated can detect those things. That's why it went away. It's not because we got better at it.
Classroom 410: It's because the ad networks got better at detecting these things. Now they're doing nasty things where they're inserting changing out Jpegs and inserting malicious code in the Jpeg of the ad. So then you get malware on your machine.
Classroom 410: Cool? All right. Any questions about
Classroom 410: any of those attack vectors. I know we spent 2 weeks on that stuff, or anything that you want to dig into that you're not sure about.
Classroom 410: Now's the time to ask.
Classroom 410: Y'all know them.
Classroom 410: Let's talk about a billion dollar hack. Why not?
Classroom 410: in terms of one of the largest banking hacks
Classroom 410: that there has been. And this is a story of policy procedures gone wrong. So we're going to talk about policy and procedure. And we're going to talk about it through the lens of the switch.
Classroom 410: Attack. Does anybody know any finance or accounting? People know what the swift network is and what it does?
Classroom 410: Yeah, it's for money transfer internationally. Yeah. So it is a pretty good target for the bad guys. Right? Let me show you how they attack this thing.
Classroom 410: Oh, Professor Lewis. I didn't check the sound again. We'll see if this works.
Classroom 410: good
Classroom 410: Reuters and other media have uncovered several cases involving hackers. Taking advantage of vulnerabilities within the international system for money transfers to Siphon at least 93 million dollars from banks in South America and Asia.
Classroom 410: The attacks all combine modern tactics of hacking into computers with malware and old fashioned money laundering skills.
Classroom 410: The most dramatic example is in Bangladesh.
Classroom 410: On February 4, th 2016 81 million dollars of Bangladesh Bank's money was moved from the New York Federal Reserve to a bank in the Philippines.
Classroom 410: That's a lot of money, but things could have been worse. They tried to transfer nearly 1 billion dollars.
Classroom 410: What do you need for a heist like this?
Classroom 410: You need some way to get into the bank's system.
Classroom 410: You need a way to gain access to the swift money transfer network.
Classroom 410: You need some malware to cover your tracks, and then you need a bank account, preferably in a lightly regulated country to receive the money.
Classroom 410: Investigators have not said how the hackers got into the computers that Bangladesh Bank uses to access the swift system.
Classroom 410: but some sources say it was probably by sending an infected email to one of the staff.
Classroom 410: Once in, they would have studied the bank's system and installed their malware. A main purpose of the malware was to cover their tracks as they committed the crime.
Classroom 410: When the staff are off work it's showtime for the hackers. They log on to the swift messaging system and start sending requests to withdraw funds. Most are rejected, but some go through. All these successful transfers go from the New York Federal Reserve and its correspondent banks to bank accounts in Sri Lanka and the Philippines.
Classroom 410: One alerts Staffer at Deutsche Bank spots a typo in the name of the intended Sri Lankan recipient and queries the transaction.
Classroom 410: The New York fed also sends multiple queries to Bangladesh Bank, but gets no response altogether. 4 requests totaling 81 million dollars are already on their way.
Classroom 410: After the requests are sent, the malware goes to work buying time for the money to be collected and laundered. It checks the swift messaging system and deletes any incoming messages that might alert bank officials about their fraudulent transfers. It also deletes any Confirmation messages before they're sent to the office printer.
Classroom 410: It's a Friday, a weekend day in Muslim, Bangladesh, and when the skeleton staff come in, all they see is an empty printer tray and an apparently broken printer.
Classroom 410: That is not that unusual. The boss tells someone to fix it and heads off for midday prayers.
Classroom 410: Meanwhile the money has landed in 4 fake accounts in a small Manila branch of a Philippine bank called Rcbc.
Classroom 410: Some of the money is transferred to another fake account in the same branch.
Classroom 410: That afternoon one of the branch employees summons an armoured car from head office which dumps 20 million pesos.
Classroom 410: Some of the staff, count the money and pack it in a paper bag.
Classroom 410: It's loaded into a car and driven off
Classroom 410: over the weekend. Bangladesh Bank officials waked to the scale of the problem.
Classroom 410: The malware appears to have disabled the swift messaging system. They print out the swift messages manually and try to contact the New York fed via phone email. And fax.
Classroom 410: there's no response from the New York Fed office that is typically not staffed on weekends.
Classroom 410: Swift, remotely fixed the messaging system. It's now Monday in Bangladesh, and officials realize where the money has gone and send swift messages to Rcbc. Asking them to stop the transfers.
Classroom 410: But it's a public holiday in the Philippines, and those messages don't get read until Tuesday morning.
Classroom 410: and crucially they're sent as ordinary messages not cancel requests, so they join a pile of hundreds of routine messages in the bank's headquarters.
Classroom 410: Eventually they're passed on to the branch, but officials in the branch ignore them and transfer the money to other accounts, with much of it ending up in Philippine casinos.
Classroom 410: Investigations are now going on around the globe, but no one has been arrested or charged.
Classroom 410: So that just gives you the very quick kind of case study here. So this is a swift network.
Classroom 410: The society for worldwide interbanking, financial telecommunications which has been around for a long time. So this is member owned, it's a cooperative and it and it allows for these banking payments to go back and forth a couple of key things. As we are digging into this right each member is assigned a unique code.
Classroom 410: and the bank name, but not only the bank name. But the country, the city, the branch, those types of things is the identifier. So one of the things that you should have picked up on was how they caught it wasn't because of all the systems in place, for all the policies in place is because the bad guys had a typo, and somebody's like that's weird. The unique code is not what this bank should be. And then that was flagged.
Classroom 410: First, st as they try to literally transfer a billion dollars, right? So the Bangladesh Central Bank, which this was about. But there were ones in Philippines and other places.
Classroom 410: etc, are targeted because they have this growing economy. Security is not as sophisticated, and frankly, the policies and laws in place are not as stringent.
Classroom 410: So part of being a fdic regulated bank is that you have stringent
Classroom 410: rules and regulations that you have to follow follow, including cyber security rules in order to operate as a bank.
Classroom 410: Other countries do not
Classroom 410: have such a sophisticated. So let me walk you through this. Just so. We kind of all understand how this was done. Right outgoing transaction goes to the swift network
Classroom 410: right? The transaction delivered as is no false positives. That's a typical thing.
Classroom 410: This transaction is then copied
Classroom 410: as well, and then it did you hear how they follow all their transactions? It's printed out in a printer.
Classroom 410: And so what the malware did. It just infected the printer
Classroom 410: and said, the printer's broken, so they didn't see the things that were coming out of the printer which didn't alert them
Classroom 410: on how to do this.
Classroom 410: And then, at this point, if it's not flagged, the decision is to send on or not, send on right. And then case managers come in and I'm showing you this because this is the policy that they built on the security on how to actually operationalize
Classroom 410: the flagging of different results. So if we look at this a little bit differently. And this is from the Financial Times story. About about this. They had 35 orders, about a billion dollars right off. 30 orders are blocked because they were improperly put in the system.
Classroom 410: but 5 orders were executed, and they went to 2 different banks, the bank in the Philippines.
Classroom 410: and this Asian Banking Corporation as well. The bank in the Philippines had accounts set up at casinos fake accounts set up through casinos.
Classroom 410: I'm unfamiliar and out of my depth when it comes to
Classroom 410: banking laws, and why you're allowed to set up accounts with casinos. But it. This is what happens.
Classroom 410: and people just withdrew the money at the casinos. Then this
Classroom 410: 20 million dollars went to a Sri Lankan Ngo and was recovered. But the stuff that was in here all of this stuff.
Classroom 410: this 88 million was eventually stolen and never recovered. Right? So this is kind of the intermediary that started at the reserve bank
Classroom 410: as well place where people put their money to be safe and then transfer it around. So we also heard what was their likely attack.
Classroom 410: The likely attack was an email. Looks like from more forensics that it was a Zip file that looked like a job applicant. Cv, that was a bank employees. So they sent them their Cv. Hey? Applying for this job? Yes, for my Cv. Here it is. Click on it. You got malware on it. The malware that infected the printing systems.
Classroom 410: and away they went. Right start infecting other. What do we call this when it moves around the network?
Classroom 410: Kylie? What do we call this.
Classroom 410: Oh, a word or
Classroom 410: the virus.
Classroom 410: It's been a long time.
Classroom 410: 3 calls. Yeah.
Classroom 410: Anyone's lateral movement, right?
Classroom 410: No worries, no worries.
Classroom 410: designed a backdoor as a lateral movement. This is the anatomy of a typical attack. This attack just took about 81 million dollars.
Classroom 410: Encrypted channel pulled out information on the back door, and software is used to scan across the network. So it wasn't sophisticated stuff.
Classroom 410: And, in fact, if you looked at the malware itself, the attackers gained access and installed this malware. And they just changed a configuration file to a particular printer.
Classroom 410: Right? Again, I'm always blown away by
Classroom 410: how innovative this is. It's like, okay, that server man that's going to be hard. It has all sorts of technology wrapped around the server to make sure people don't can't attack the server. But this printer configuration file. Nobody's going to notice that.
Classroom 410: So away we go. The printer doesn't do it until you log in and manually check things.
Classroom 410: You can print those off right? So
Classroom 410: incredibly complex. Swift system. No problem. I'm just gonna change a printer config file, and away I go.
Classroom 410: Human error
Classroom 410: was the most prevalent of this
Classroom 410: like
Classroom 410: this was part of the issues, is their procedures and their guidelines, and what the things that they put in place
Classroom 410: don't didn't actually raise to a level that would protect all of these things. And the only reason is because they made a mistake that they didn't get away with 1 billion dollars.
Classroom 410: So the lessons learned surprise surprise humans are the weakest link. We've been saying that for a while, right?
Classroom 410: 81 million was stolen with fishing. 90 million was stopped because of a human.
Classroom 410: not because of
Classroom 410: the multi 1 million dollar cyber security technology that they built around the swift, you know.
Classroom 410: So this is the story about why policies and procedures are so critically important.
Classroom 410: because these are the things that are under attack. Right? So
Classroom 410: what do you think you know, in terms of this, what do you think we could change just spitballing in terms of what did we learn? And what did we change? What you would change, knowing what you know now, and after your particular reading like, think about in terms of
Classroom 410: the policy, or a different procedure on what you would do to make sure
Classroom 410: some attack like this or similar attack doesn't happen. So I'm going to let you huddle up for a couple of minutes with your usual suspect of teams, and then we'll be going around like we usually do to think about. All right.
Classroom 410: we need to fix this and policy. Believe it or not is the way to fix this. How do we do this
Classroom 410: sound good?
Classroom 410: Give you a few minutes to discuss this. We'll come back. I want to hear about your ideas.
Classroom 410: Try and come up with 3 things.
Classroom 410: That's exactly what I was worried about.
Classroom 410: Alright. 3 things you do want, 3 things from every group that you do
Classroom 410: alright. 3 things I'll give you 3 more minutes to do 3 things from every group.
Classroom 410: 2 more minutes
Classroom 410: figured. That was
Classroom 410: sounds. We're quieting down. It sounds like we're ready to go. Is that right?
Classroom 410: Everybody got 3? I think I started on this side of the room last time. Right as well. Let's start. Hey, sonny, let's start with your group. So what does that mean like who has access to stuff that might make that more solidified process.
Classroom 410: Yeah, so that's 1 of our pillars, too. Right?
Classroom 410: Absolutely. So. I might come back to you
Classroom 410: as well. How about you all?
Classroom 410: One of those are creating a stronger security awareness within, like the bank's employees, to be able to recognize risk, and also
Classroom 410: how severe the consequences may be if they get breach.
Classroom 410: Let me ask you a hard question.
Classroom 410: How do you do that?
Classroom 410: I'm gonna tell you. In 3 classes. The thesis of my presentation is training sucks and doesn't work
Classroom 410: right? And we're gonna have to solve that problem together. And I'm gonna show you all the empirical evidence in the world is why training is broken
Classroom 410: in terms of cybersecurity.
Classroom 410: And then I'm gonna ask you to do a case on, how do we fix training?
Classroom 410: And how do we fix education? Because showing a couple of videos and doing a couple of things is not cutting it right. It's not cutting not to pick on you. But that is definitely going to be something we're going to be talking more about.
Classroom 410: Neil. Aisha. Yeah. So
Classroom 410: training was one thing. By the way training is a good answer. That's not what I'm saying. I'm saying how training is instituted in most organizations makes no sense whatsoever.
Classroom 410: just to be clear. So don't like. Oh, yeah, we screwed that. It's not. It is the right answer. It's the poor execution that we're talking about. So all right. Now. Say more confidently. Training training was one thing, yeah, an idea like I have for the training. I don't know if this is like a 5 like
Classroom 410: can like if training usually sucks. Can't you just have, like fake attacks executed just to see, like, like imitate, like real ones perfect. We're going to talk tons more about what the right training profile should look like in a modern organization.
Classroom 410: Just give me a week and a half, and that's a case you're going to be working on as well. That's exactly the right way to start thinking about it like rather than like sitting who is sat through cyber security training just out of curiosity.
Classroom 410: Right? So we all most of us know that it's not very good.
Classroom 410: I think they all have to. Don't you all have to, shouldn't you? Always?
Classroom 410: Yeah. You all should have raised your hand. Good job, exactly my exact point. You don't even know if you've gone through cyberspace.
Classroom 410: So
Classroom 410: Hannah Jesse, did you have anything to add?
Classroom 410: We also talked about like account verification policies, that they had a lot of fake accounts. So
Classroom 410: having those structured policies to make sure that doesn't happen.
Classroom 410: Yeah, here's a trick question. Let me see if I can
Classroom 410: trick you with this.
Classroom 410: You just came in
Classroom 410: to fix all the problems with Swift as their new Chief Information Security Officer. What's the 1st thing you do
Classroom 410: and
Classroom 410: ask with the existing policies inventory right like that? Am I trying to drive home that point today? I think so right, we gotta figure out what's going on and how things are done and including it is figuring out the policies and procedures on how how things are kind of rolled out as well.
Classroom 410: All right. Where do you want to start? Let's go here.
Classroom 410: So we also have the accessibility and the training as well. And we are also thinking about not only regular audits, but also random audits
Classroom 410: of log security logs everything like that, just so that
Classroom 410: in case there is like a pattern it can still be disrupted at some point.
Classroom 410: an attacker won't have access to the information of when that random audit is going to take place, because it's going to be random
Classroom 410: according to today's reading. Who does those audit?
Classroom 410: What's the
Classroom 410: function in a business organization?
Classroom 410: You guys remember
Classroom 410: security Operations Center.
Classroom 410: we're gonna talk a little bit about the security operations center today, what they do and the tools that they use, because those are the types of things they should be definitely.
Classroom 410: They go with appropriate classification of
Classroom 410: files.
Classroom 410: maybe the ones that could lead to a tech like this are harder to get to. Yeah.
Classroom 410: Sunny Rajan. I only let you do one. I'll let you do more, since everybody else is doing more now.
Classroom 410: Okay, well, I understand already. Okay.
Classroom 410: But
Classroom 410: we also said, like, maybe a better anomaly detection system
Classroom 410: policies in place to set that up.
Classroom 410: How do you know if something's an anomaly
Classroom 410: because you have a policy in place that tells you what's an anomaly like that? The thing is is when you talk about the technology and you lead with, the technology is like, Oh, we got this cool machine learning thing that detects anomalies. That's amazing. What's an anomaly. Oh, I don't know. You got to define it, and you got to write it down right in terms of that. What about Carl Jonathan?
Classroom 410: He also said, this is more of a human thing, but a limited physical presence should be required at the banks, regardless of holidays or weekends
Classroom 410: staffing. So you think like, Hey, if people work weekends, this never would happen. Maybe I think you could argue the same thing at target. Remember, we talked about that. They pick like. They're smart about this, and they know when the security they know when the socks are
Classroom 410: are present and not, and I'll I'll I'll we'll talk more about the side. Yeah, Jonathan, we also talked about like using a clean desk clean screen
Classroom 410: policy. So like.
Classroom 410: you don't need any complimentary information like on your desktop.
Classroom 410: Yeah, what were they doing with confidential? They're literally like printing it out, and it'd be a stack, and they would go through like, Is that not crazy for you folks, for like
Classroom 410: 1 billion dollars that are floating around on how this was thought it was like, Oh, that then we'll do. We'll print it out, and that sounds like a good idea right?
Classroom 410: Like that. Just seems crazy when you walk through it as well.
Classroom 410: you all we mentioned having better remediation procedures to what they said about the fact that it was like a weekend and a holiday, and that's why there wasn't any follow up on whatever was happening. It's pretty bad. So yeah, by the way, most of you all are spending money by your solutions
Classroom 410: like, let's recognize that for a second, that we have finite resources a lot of times, especially if we're an emerging bank or something like that. And we're all saying, Let's throw money at this problem as well. It's another reason why you want to start with policies and procedures, because that's free
Classroom 410: and understanding those things is free. Yeah. Another thing that I read was like separation of duties or job rotations
Classroom 410: so like, not the same.
Classroom 410: Exactly. That's just good accounting controls, right? Like that's that's not cyber security accounting controls should handle that. So if you think like, oh, we have cyber security audit problems is like, you probably have accounting audit problems, too. If you're not doing the right things
Classroom 410: as well.
Classroom 410: You're proud of my accounting knowledge. By the way, that's all of it right there. So there is no more
Classroom 410: you all.
Classroom 410: We also kind of said the fact that. And you mentioned earlier the fact that, like the printer, is basically their record of the confidential information, and that they were kind of used to it. Having issues, they should have some sort of backup. The printer always goes down.
Classroom 410: No big deal
Classroom 410: that's crazy. I can. Yeah, I love digging into these things. It's like, I can't believe that happened multimillion dollar organization.
Classroom 410: But walk into any multimillion dollar organization. And you're gonna see a procedure, a guideline of policies like this makes no sense. I can't believe we're doing this type of thing
Classroom 410: you folks we kind of just talked about keeping track of any phishing emails and just having that in some type of system that alerts every time.
Classroom 410: Yeah, we'll talk more about phishing. We'll talk about those systems. And there's even things that we'll talk about and experiments. We ran in organizations about things like identifying phishing emails, shame boards. How effective things like that are as well. If you click on a message, you go up on a board.
Classroom 410: Really interesting results that we've we've done in organizations about that. Yeah, we also said flagging any transactions over 100 k. Over a mil or whatever the bank wants to choose. It's interesting. I don't know enough about the swift system to know what that threshold could be. These could be under that, because you can imagine the amount of money that's flowing around an international banking transfer system. So 81 million might have been like, that's no big deal
Classroom 410: right? That's and how they broke it up to. If you go back at how they broke it up into 30 orders or 35 orders altogether. The Federal Reserve Bank, that was probably strategic to be under any threshold, right?
Classroom 410: Or else they would have done one order for 1 billion dollars. And let's just see what happens there. Right?
Classroom 410: So yes. But your point is well taken. Taking a look at those
Classroom 410: anything from this side of the room, finally getting to you. Let's have some smart things to say.
Classroom 410: Good job. Lots been said. Do you have anything to add? I think you probably heard a lot of it. That's why I try and switch the sides of the room, because most of it said, Yeah, this might. This is kind of more in hindsight. But there should definitely be policy and ideology of like
Classroom 410: after the fact, observing like
Classroom 410: cause, I think you kind of mentioned it. But
Classroom 410: technically
Classroom 410: they block 6 out of 7 of the attempts. So 6 out of 7, they did. Well, yeah, observing really what really went wrong with the one I saw it previously.
Classroom 410: that's actually a really really good point. And there's 2 things. So in the military they call those hot washes retrospectives is probably what you learn, and and 3,200, or even com 1,800 about those
Classroom 410: I can't tell you how important those are in a cyber security context. And there's 2 kind of ways to think about it. One is looking what we've done in the past is really important.
Classroom 410: But MoD 3 is practicing all these skills. So we have companies. And Terry Pearlson Mit does these things all the time where you'll have a board of directors. Sit down and you'll say this is what's happening in your organization. What do you all do? What are your policies, procedures. How do you handle these? And you run these tabletop simulations kind of over and over, because those will surface problems. We're like, Oh, for example.
Classroom 410: one of the problems it might service in a tabletop organization is like, we're going to pay the ransomware like, how do we get Bitcoin? Nobody knows.
Classroom 410: Matt, do you want to put your personal account on Bitcoin to pay the bad guys? Nobody wants to do that right? Like. So that's great. When you say in theory. Okay, we're going to pay the ransom. But you actually haven't practiced it. You don't know how to do that thing.
Classroom 410: We're gonna do tabletop simulations with you all. Well, we'll give you simulations, and you go away. The same simulations that they give to board of directors that you all go away and tell me how you're gonna address these different things?
Classroom 410: And then we're going to come back and and do hot washing about it. To figure out. Would you do differently. What did we learn together? And those things happen in really successful organizations, not only for cyber security, but for kind of best practices in general
Classroom 410: and I'm sure, like in the integrated core in the com, 3,200. You've heard about this.
Classroom 410: The best companies in the world do this and do it at the highest levels all the way down the organization. So they're always practicing.
Classroom 410: And we know that. And that includes, you know, some of the most
Classroom 410: well trained teams in the world, and they've done studies on this with the seal teams as well. What they do better than everybody is hot washers, they learn from their mistakes. So this is what we got to do in cybersecurity to learn from their mistakes.
Classroom 410: And this is what the Big 4 do really well is, they'll come in and they'll put you through these paces
Classroom 410: to make sure you, as an organization, are prepared for all these weirdo scenarios and your policies and procedures are in place.
Classroom 410: Good! Any questions. Before I move on, I want to underline something that I just kind of skim by the last class. That's kind of part of
Classroom 410: your
Classroom 410: tool set as you move forward, and you do things like tabletop simulations and the group exams.
Classroom 410: etc. But I want to pause here and see if you had any questions about that case.
Classroom 410: Makes sense. Does it surprise anybody about how
Classroom 410: trillion dollar? So money flows around, and that was their
Classroom 410: that's how they do it.
Classroom 410: like, I think, going back to like, oh, why don't we just do the 5 pillars? And
Classroom 410: I would argue 6 pillars, and we're good like that is such a valuable insight in general
Classroom 410: to how you proceed.
Classroom 410: So we talked briefly about minor attack, and I think we ended class. So I'm gonna assume this is new. And if it's not new for you, it's review for you.
Classroom 410: So
Classroom 410: Mitre is a nonprofit group.
Classroom 410: and they do several different things. One of the things they've done in cyber security is they've actually created this attack library. Right? It's called mitre attack, and in the Mitre Attack Library it tells you all the different ways. Your organizations can be attacked by the bad guys.
Classroom 410: So it goes through our kind of steps here. Their steps are a little bit different than the ones we talked about. But basically it is. Instead of scanning, they say, recon, for example, recon weaponization, deliver, exploit, control, execute, maintain is their chain. There's not something that Professor Lewis mentioned, which was the cyber security kill chain. These are all really similar on how
Classroom 410: we think about cyber security attacks happening.
Classroom 410: So they have the pre attack.
Classroom 410: and then they have attack for enterprise, for Mobile, for everything. But here is like, here's everything they'll ever do. And I want to show you their their website. So you can see this as you go through. And you look at their matrix.
Classroom 410: And there's there's 330 known
Classroom 410: tactics. So these aren't 330 malware. These are 330 tactics
Classroom 410: on how they do things. Some of these should look really familiar to you
Classroom 410: in terms of the tactics on how they do things on the particular network initial access soon as they get initial access execution. There's 34 different tactics that they know about persistence. So they stay in the network
Classroom 410: privilege ex escalation, so they can get that admin password, defense, evasion, credential access, discovery, lateral movement, which which is, believe it or not, is not my favorite word, but I say it, a lot
Classroom 410: collection command and control exfiltration, taking data out and impact for all things.
Classroom 410: So if we look at, let's see if it breaks this. Oh.
Classroom 410: the attack website. And it's a resource that I gave to you.
Classroom 410: It just gives you kind of all of these different things. So this is the Enterprise windows, Max and Linux and well, what we don't want you to know is, go. Oh, what is a recon
Classroom 410: gathering victim identification information you click on there and like, here's all the procedures, and you'll see. Apt, did this
Classroom 410: lapsis did this, which is a group we know about magichound, which is one we haven't known about, did this, but it just gives you a sense of how different actors have attacked particular networks, which is a super handy tool even for executives, as they're saying, Okay, is there something similar out there that we're undergoing? So when you're doing
Classroom 410: the simulations, you can use this resource to see. Okay, this is what we should expect next, based on this type of attack
Classroom 410: as well.
Classroom 410: So everybody thinks their attacks are so novel and so interesting and and brand new. The fact of the matter is, 99% of attacks are running a playbook just like you're running a playbook against them. Here's the 6 steps I got to do to get in the network
Classroom 410: right? And then we have that 1%. Those nation state actors that do like
Classroom 410: really interesting work, like build their own Stuxnet virus that looks for a controller on a centrifuge.
Classroom 410: Type of thing. But those are rest.
Classroom 410: So I wanted to introduce you to this as another tool, if you're saying, Oh, I'm doing a tabletop simulation. What could be next? Well, they could do privilege access next. Where they get get up they could do defense, evasion. Next, they could do some lateral movement. And what do we need to do to protect our network.
Classroom 410: And the Sony attack, which is, it's a decade now, old, right? Maybe more than a decade old where they released the movies because they made some movies about the North Koreans. They were mad about that. So they released Sony's. All their emails shut down their networks with ransomware wasn't really even ransomware, because some of it was hashed, meaning they could never reverse it. So they were just destructive
Classroom 410: in terms of of what that is. They ended up literally as this was going on, literally pulling plugs out of computers to stop the infection
Classroom 410: like going around and trying to do this as a ciso, as we heard was at the side of the road on a cell phone trying to contain this
Classroom 410: a particular attack.
Classroom 410: So you know, you know a little bit more about what's next.
Classroom 410: You can kind of prevent it, and this will help you kind of what's next. So play around with this, take a look at this and
Classroom 410: and we'll we'll it might be a good tool for you to kind of predict
Classroom 410: what's next. If you're doing simulations, or you're trying to respond to something
Classroom 410: didn't
Classroom 410: great.
Classroom 410: So
Classroom 410: this is a long way to get to the reading right?
Classroom 410: So I'm gonna assume that
Classroom 410: everybody here has read. And I'm going to assume that everybody has a question that they've just been burning about the reading or other things we we did. So do you all get a chance to write something down, or do you need a minute?
Classroom 410: Sounds like we're good thumbs up, thumbs up.
Classroom 410: love to hear your questions.
Classroom 410: So I'm gonna start on this side of the room. Matthew.
Classroom 410: yeah.
Classroom 410: I feel like, for
Classroom 410: one thing, I was thinking about as I was reading through. It was like, as far as it goes, like the baselines, the guidelines, the policies. It sounds like they kind of all are.
Classroom 410: I'm kind of struggling to see the difference between some of them, because it seems like they kind of great insight.
Classroom 410: great insight, and sometimes even experts struggle to see the difference between them. So I'll dive more into that. That's a great question. Like, what's the difference between a baseline and a guideline and a policy and a framework? And how all these things happen. I think that's yeah. Well, I'll get to that question.
Classroom 410: Alex, do you have anything mine was kind of on, like the personnel security principles, and like one of them was, or like 2 of them were like job rotations and mandatory vacations, mandatory vacations. I'm okay with that one. The way I saw it was like, wouldn't that be kind of a negative to the company like if you maybe forcing somebody to go on vacation just to do a security check?
Classroom 410: so that I was kind of curious on that. And
Classroom 410: is that kind of net, positive or negative, critical?
Classroom 410: That's a good question. I have a personal opinion. I'm gonna ask Professor Lewis's for his personal opinion
Classroom 410: on
Classroom 410: yeah, I'll give you. I'll bail you out. I'll give you my personal. That's hardcore, right? Like even job. Rotation makes a lot of sense in an in an audit sense, but in practice it is extremely difficult to do
Classroom 410: extremely difficult.
Classroom 410: So how they do that, and we'll look at what the security operations centers do is they may change how the analysts and what they're actually analyzing.
Classroom 410: Now the go on vacation, or you're in trouble thing. That's that's pretty hardcore. Right?
Classroom 410: Yeah, good insight.
Classroom 410: I also had a similar question about the differences between the baseline and everything. But then another one was in talking about the data classification. How do you actually measure like what is valuable or sensitive? Oh, that's great. We're going to talk about that. That's great.
Classroom 410: Am I just blowing off all your questions here right now? And yeah, I promise we'll we'll talk about them. Let's do a couple more I'll get in, and then I'll come back, because I think all this lives in this deck as well.
Classroom 410: Eleanor, do you want to do one.
Classroom 410: Yes, one of mine was also about mandatory vacations, but the other one was like kind of similar to Marley's, like in the event logs when you're trying to determine, like.
Classroom 410: how much I feel like that's a ton of information to keep track of everyone's traffic. I'm not even going to get a different one, because that's also 2 slides away from kind of seeing these things. And what I need to introduce you to really is these policy frameworks, the data, classification standards and the frameworks and playbooks as things. But yeah, I want to start with like, this is the people
Classroom 410: the Isoc, or Soc, as it's sometimes called is the Security Operations center. So this is the people that are doing the work that's written down
Classroom 410: right? So this is a picture of of an isock that is a stock footage picture. Just so, you know.
Classroom 410: But this is, you know, for larger organizations. This is kind of what it looks like in terms of. They're looking for anomalies. They're looking. They're tracking things down, etc. But I want to give you even further insights on what these analysts do
Classroom 410: for this. So I'm going to show you. Let's defend and let's defend is it is a for free hands-on training. But let's defend will actually show you some of the tools that are used by these, what they call blue teamers, the ones that are protecting as they're tracking down all the anomalies that have been flagged by all our systems because we set up policies to say what anomalies are.
Classroom 410: So let's look at this. And then we're gonna also look at the volume on how this is done. So this is an example of what an analyst would do and what they would look like. And there are. I don't know countless systems.
Classroom 410: about this. So example investigation.
Classroom 410: In order to start investigating alerts, we must 1st start working on by taking the relevant alert on the main channel.
Classroom 410: we should choose the alert that we will start working on with a high criticality level
Classroom 410: when we investigate the priorities of the alerts on the main channel.
Classroom 410: we see that there are high and medium alerts.
Classroom 410: We can begin to investigate the high priority alert with event. Id. 19.
Classroom 410: In order to start investigating the alert, we must take the ownership of the relevant alert
Classroom 410: for this. We must use the take ownership button on the right side of the alert.
Classroom 410: With this button
Classroom 410: the ownership of the selected Alert is transferred to you
Classroom 410: and to the investigation channel.
Classroom 410: which is the alert review channel.
Classroom 410: We made sure that the names of the rules are understandable.
Classroom 410: but you can get the information from the tutorial use cases menu to find out in which situations the rule is triggered.
Classroom 410: So the reason I show you this I won't show you the completed video of this is this is what they're doing is they're like, here's our system outfit. It's hard to see. But you see, one is malware. The other one is the exchange server which has to do with mail. The other 2 are malware. One's a possible ransomware activity, the other ones of a privilege. Escalation is what it says on there.
Classroom 410: So an analyst shows up, has a list of things, of violations, of policies and procedures that the network is doing and goes through and investigates these. That's literally what they're doing and tracking them. We have people at Uva that this is their job
Classroom 410: is they go in and they figure out, okay, that's weird. Neil's computers talking to Alex's computer. They shouldn't talk to each other flags and anomaly. So they go and look to see what that is. That's the logging that's the auditing part that's going on. These are all set up. But here's the reality. So typical organizations at.
Classroom 410: you know, fortune. 1,000 companies are about 12 person teams. They're staffed 24HA day at these organizations. They're dealing with 3,800 alerts per day using the methods that I just showed you.
Classroom 410: That's
Classroom 410: somebody do the math for me. Really quick. What's 3,800 divided by 12,
Classroom 410: 360.
Classroom 410: So they're dealing with about 350 alerts per day per person.
Classroom 410: That sounds crazy, doesn't it?
Classroom 410: So they have to have rules, and they have. So everything can't be alert. And, in fact, one of the things about the target attack when they exfiltrated all the customer data is their systems gave them alerts. This was happening that were ignored. It was like, how could they possibly be ignored? Well, they're ignored because they probably had. This was one out of 400 different alerts that that analyst was going through
Classroom 410: in order to do that.
Classroom 410: So if you talk to the socks and the challenges and the analysts, most of them are most worried that they're going to miss a real attack because the volume of things that they see
Classroom 410: right
Classroom 410: things like.
Classroom 410: let's just pretend you plug in your Internet scale
Classroom 410: to the Uva network.
Classroom 410: or your Xbox, or whatever it might be. And then your Xbox does something funny and goes to a website or your scale does something funny and goes to a website. It shouldn't. That'll create an alert. How many alerts you think our Uva network creates based on anomalous behavior? It must be crazy.
Classroom 410: That's a good question for the sizzle. So let me write that down.
Classroom 410: You could steal that one from me. If you want
Classroom 410: happen to believe they can't keep pace.
Classroom 410: 3 quarters of them have not one of those tools like I showed you but 10 of the tools, a little less than half have 20 tools that they're monitoring that are producing these alerts.
Classroom 410: Man, this is hard all of a sudden, right? This is really really hard, and this is why policies and procedures are critical because we need to hardline things. So we're not over alerting.
Classroom 410: And we have to protect ourselves. So we're not under alerting as well.
Classroom 410: Yeah, what's kind of like the average time it takes for somebody to
Classroom 410: figure out like whether this is like an attack or it's not. Yeah. I don't have a good number there, but I'll tell you. I'll talk about in standard deviation and the and the reason I'm talking about standard deviations, because it's so different where one thing you could solve in an instant and another one might take you weeks as you're tracking down exactly what's going on
Classroom 410: right? So the standard deviations are huge, so average means nothing in terms of if you have huge standard deviations, right
Classroom 410: in terms of that.
Classroom 410: Does that make sense? What I just said.
Classroom 410: good question about this as well. So this is the problem. It's like, we're we have all these policies and procedures. And if we're way, too stringent. We're just gonna overwhelm our ability to chase down all the alerts.
Classroom 410: And if we're way, too lax.
Classroom 410: that's gonna be a problem, too. We're gonna miss things that don't even show up as alerts.
Classroom 410: That's why hot washing or force modems, or whatever you want to call you are so important. So you have an activity, and then you go back and evaluate your policies like, okay, we missed this, or it took X long. Why did this happen?
Classroom 410: That's the only way to get better on these things. So these policy tools.
Classroom 410: or really, this is what's driving these policy tools is how much networks are monitored and how much technology and people we spent in them. So we talked about service level bank purchase agreements, memorandum of understanding and interconnection security agreements. I think most of these are pretty
Classroom 410: self explanatory.
Classroom 410: you know. Service service level agreements is like you're gonna have X uptime. And you're gonna be down 5 days a year. Type of thing. Type of thing mous are and I know our new
Classroom 410: CIO is big on mo use
Classroom 410: in terms of even between schools and things like that? Or was it our old one that was big on new one? Yeah. So they're just writing like, this is our expectations. This is your expectations. This is how it should be done. So these are kind of the tools that that they're using. But let's talk about
Classroom 410: I think the questions that a couple of you had policies.
Classroom 410: standards, procedures, baselines.
Classroom 410: and guidelines. And, by the way, like all of this.
Classroom 410: is driven by frameworks. So the frameworks will tell you when you look at the NIST slides, and you say.
Classroom 410: for example, 1st step is to figure out what assets you have on your network.
Classroom 410: And I said this before, but I want to make sure everybody understands it.
Classroom 410: If you dive into that things, there is 60 more sub points under understanding how exactly what you do for your assets, and what the steps are, and what you do. So for every one of those categories, 5 categories. You blow it out. You have 5 more, and for each one of those you probably have 10 more. You can see there's all of a sudden this turns into oh, there's 3,000 things I need to do to secure my network.
Classroom 410: That's true, right? So the framework will tell you. Here's your policies. Here's your standards. Here's your procedure, and here's your baseline, right? So this looks familiar to you. I think the best way to show it, and to answer kind of these questions
Classroom 410: is an understanding what a policy is. And then, taking a look at the Uva policies, that's something you kind of understand what they are because of the contacts we're in here. So we'll we'll jump into those real briefly. But a policy is the articulation of your strategy.
Classroom 410: That's what a policy is very high level.
Classroom 410: So an organizational security policy will be very high level. It'll be written for top management. It's like, this is our approach. This is what's important to us, protecting research.
Classroom 410: Securing data. A lot of this is also driven by things like Urpa and hipaa.
Classroom 410: which is law based things right?
Classroom 410: So that's the organization level security policy. And that's the articulation of strategy.
Classroom 410: And so what common thing is, what's the difference between that and functional functional is is basically these are the things that are rolled out in terms of what we need to do.
Classroom 410: So some examples of functional policies that are implemented for a strategy is acceptable. Use, email, use, antivirus.
Classroom 410: etc.
Classroom 410: And then the supporting mechanisms. And this is a key difference. So we have organizational policy, strategy.
Classroom 410: functional policy is ha is different features within the organization. Right supporting mechanisms, standards are the specific products and mechanisms used to support the policies. We use this technology as a standard. This is our malware. We use this technology as our routers. We use this technology as XY or Z,
Classroom 410: so that's the standard is the products and mechanisms used
Classroom 410: to support the policy.
Classroom 410: The procedures are the actions that you take
Classroom 410: implied by the policy. So what happens when somebody goes abroad with a laptop. Well, we have an export control procedure that we have to run to make sure these are done.
Classroom 410: Standards are the technology we use. Procedures are the actions we take. The baselines is, defines the minimum requirements. And I talked about baselines last time. It's like, so, Jesse, we give Jesse a brand new laptop. She's a Uva employee. Congratulations. You get to be a professor. Here's your laptop. Baseline is what are the minimum things that need to happen on this piece of hardware in order for the baseline to be met.
Classroom 410: things that we do for every computer, every server, everything. What are our baselines, baselines to protect our network. So when we spin up a new switch, here's the baseline on how we do a new switch when we spin up a
Classroom 410: a new computer. Here's the things we do, including one of our baselines, is encrypting the drive right like that is a common practice encrypting the drive. Why would we want to encrypt the drive. Somebody steals it, pulls the drive out, puts it in another machine that's encrypted. They can't read it.
Classroom 410: In terms of that that's a common thing.
Classroom 410: And then guidelines
Classroom 410: are kind of defined recommendations. Here's what we all should be doing.
Classroom 410: In terms of that. So that's the easiest way to see that I want to show you what these look like.
Classroom 410: Another example of a procedure is an incident response plan.
Classroom 410: So if you're thinking of.
Classroom 410: you know. What do I do when we have a particular action? Well, this is the particular procedure I would use. Every university has several of these.
Classroom 410: As we go as we go through as well.
Classroom 410: An example of a guideline I probably missed. That is like when you back up your particular data. When you use Vpns, those are guidelines as well.
Classroom 410: Does that help clarify what those things are? A little bit.
Classroom 410: Standard policies is strategy. Functional policies is within areas.
Classroom 410: Standard is a product. Procedure is the action. Baseline is the minimum requirements and guidelines. I don't know. Can I say guidelines or guidelines?
Classroom 410: and get away with that with you all. Does that make sense?
Classroom 410: So that is our hierarchy. This is what you define. And, by the way, it's not only for
Classroom 410: cyber security. It's
Classroom 410: literally for everything. So this is how you run organizations
Classroom 410: is your articulation of your strategy shows up in these types of documents. We're just talking cyber security. But as eventually you're all become Ceos, and see how important policy hierarchy is
Classroom 410: not the coolest thing to talk about. I realize. So this is the standard procedures and guidelines at Uva.
Classroom 410: So electronic data removal believe it or not is something that's really interesting to us. Right? I tried to write on the screen. Sorry.
Classroom 410: high sensitive data protection. And we'll talk about that last question here in a second university's data protection standards, then the procedures on how to do that. And then the guidelines. Here's the security tools, guidelines. Here's
Classroom 410: electronically stored information released those types of things. So these are all articulated. And you can Google them on a website as well.
Classroom 410: Fun stuff. I think the last question was about data classification, which is where we're ending today's lecture, anyways.
Classroom 410: so classification, it's the do. This is
Classroom 410: when you talk about assess or take inventory of things. The 1st thing you do is, you take an inventory of your yes.
Classroom 410: your network assets. The second thing you do is you take an inventory of your data assets and you classify them because you protect them differently.
Classroom 410: just like those layers. When we talked about anatomy of a phishing attack where we have that one computer that was really well secured, and then the servers were somewhat secured, the other ones was secured less. We make those same types of things on classifying information.
Classroom 410: So we have valuable, sensitive, and critical. What they talked about in the book, I think an easier way to think about this is the Us. Government standardization classified, unrestricted, confidential, secret and top secret. But most organizations have this
Classroom 410: public, private, confidential. This is the right way to think about these things in terms of. So the question was like, how do I know it's public? How do I know it's private? And how do I know it's confidential? Right? That was the question most of the time. It's the laws that tell you this
Classroom 410: so highly sensitive pii, highly sensitive, personal, identifiable information, birth dates, social security, numbers, partial social security numbers, those types of things are all driven by laws or hipaa health laws or ferpa. So they'll tell you. This is highly sensitive information.
Classroom 410: etc. You know, there's moderately sensitive information. Things like
Classroom 410: university id numbers, public records, non public records that are ferpa like your grades.
Classroom 410: or anything withheld from foia like Hr files. Those are moderately sensitive information. In terms of your organization, foia, freedom of access. So anybody that's a citizen of Virginia can access
Classroom 410: public records from any state entity. This is a state entity, obviously, and they can say things like, Hey, I'd like to know this or that just because you do. Foia doesn't mean you have to give up that information. If it's sensitive or moderately sensitive information like somebody's Hr. File that does not give it up. It's also protected differently.
Classroom 410: and then you have all this internal use, public records. This is all subject to foia, salary, information, contracts, etc.
Classroom 410: So the quick answer to all of this when you're talking about data.
Classroom 410: and public is like what's on public websites. It's mostly driven by your legal team about how you classify that. And then you're going to make some decisions where different things lie. But things like grades that's defined by Ferpa, things like health records that's defined by hipaa, personal, identifiable information that's defined by State law.
Classroom 410: Those types of things we're going to dig more into that. So was that helpful for you, Eleanor? That didn't exactly answer your question, but the good thing is, if I asked this on a test you go. My lawyer would tell me
Classroom 410: what exactly classified information, what how to classify different information. But you should be able to provide examples. And I showed you a bunch of examples here.
Classroom 410: Sound, good. Okay, we're like couple of minutes over. We're exactly where we need to be.
Classroom 410: I think I by accidentally gave you all the answers to the quiz anyways, but go ahead and take it, and see if you're paying attention whatsoever for that, and then have a good weekend. We've only seen them once, and, I get to say, have a good weekend
Classroom 410: congratulations. Bonus question, what we call that a bonus question. It's a bonus question. But please answer the question, because
Classroom 410: that's the right. Gave you an answer in class.
Classroom 410: Yeah, but we're fair
Classroom 410: answer that. I'll hang out up here if you need anything for a little bit. You know we're having a Chili cook off.
Classroom 410: That wasn't as painful as I remember.
Classroom 410: No, the exercise was full.
Classroom 410: Yeah, I couldn't do
Classroom 410: just it helps.